why do people
freak out about barbecue yeah why
because you go and it smells bomb it
smells so
good it smells like heaven right it
smells fatty and delicious and the
smells
everywhere and everyone's smelling the
same smell so there's like this
collective experience
it's incredible that's i mean i i think
that's why barbecue is so
sticky for people yeah it's like so
yummy
and you get this huge like anticipatory
thing about it it's like because it
smells incredible
what was that incredible grill that we
used yesterday what is that that's
called a sea island forge
it's a wood fire grill that's inspired
by like a south american style cooking
so it's like it's big it has also the
the things with the crank it allows you
to control the distance from the flame
it's awesome really key with the wood
fire so when we evolved
um from cooking over wood to charcoal
right when when that became more popular
the reason that we did that
is that allowed us to skip the whole
part of making our own charcoal
right so when you're cooking over wood
all you're doing is making your own
charcoal
you don't ever cook over wood with the
red fire like we don't like
throw a steak on when the flames are
orange and leaping up because you're
just gonna get
you know carbon like char all over your
meat so you're when you're cooking over
wood
you first cook down the wood you create
the coal base the natural coal base
and then you cook over that so you saw
yesterday i built my fire i let it burn
down added some fresh wood so i could
reinforce
my coals with new coals coming in but
then
i was actually cooking over the embers
you shorten that cycle with carbon
with with charcoal it's more it's more
efficient but what you lose is that
whole cycle
of you know that really beautiful
experience of smelling
now if you're cooking on a traeger
you're gonna get awesome smoke smell you
know like you're
there's plenty of ways to do this it
doesn't always have to be wood fire and
i
love all the different ways right but i
i really like
the experience of the campfire and i
love that kind of just like sitting by
it building it having to take the time i
like building the fire
going inside preparing all my meats
bringing them out cooking them that
whole experience start to finish
is really just like something that it's
my favorite it's my favorite way to
spend it
spend time you know so i think and why
is that is the food that different than
cooking it in a
in a more conventional grill probably
not you know like in a pure
experience but i think the actual
experience is super memorable
because you are outside you are slowing
your role you're enjoying the
this you know you're just taking in
you're watching
you're anticipating i love that whole
experience
you